without further ado it's a great
pleasure to welcome a colleague from MIT
professor Robert Horvitz he's an MIT
alumnus class of nineteen sixty-eight
went to another university down the road
to do his PhD but for many years has
been a distinguished member of the
faculty back here at MIT and he's the
David Koch professor of biology here and
a member of the McGovern Institute for
brain research professor Horvitz is
known for a great deal of distinguished
research in biology but perhaps best
known of all for work with a model
organism famous amongst biologists a
nematode worm called keno rev lattice
elegans on which he pioneered work in
the study of development particularly
programmed cell death which has
widespread implications about which
perhaps he may choose to talk for our
understanding of human embryo logical
development of cancer and of many
different diseases he is the recipient
of the Orrico recipient of the 2002
nobel prize for physiology and medicine
for some of that work so it's a great
pleasure professor hope it's to have you
with us and I'm going to hand over to
you okay thank you very much
so I want to start by saying thank you
for those of you who decided to come and
join this conversation I'll tell you a
little bit about myself but I don't know
who's in the audience both within sight
and those of you who are out of sight so
if they when we come to the questions
I'd like to know a little bit about the
context in which they're coming from and
who is who is here joining us this
afternoon I'd also like to extend a
personal greeting to the folks in Cairo
I have visited Cairo twice it's a great
city it's a great country and I'm there
with you presumably in sight and
certainly in spirit great ok so what i
thought i would do is start with a few
comments about my personal history
people often ask you know where did you
come from and how did you get a Nobel
Prize I can answer the former I'm not
entirely sure I can answer the the
letter in detail but what I'll do is
tell you a little bit about my
background and then something about the
Nobel Prize receiving research and then
basically open it up to discussion there
are many possible things I would be
happy to chat about and i'll leave it to
folks here to to raise questions so
first I grew up in Chicago and my my
parents both also were from Chicago they
were born in Chicago so I really was
Chicago born and raised and my father
very much wanted to be a chemist a
scientist but the family finances were
such that he simply could not afford to
go to school in fact I think it's fair
to say that when he was in elementary
school he could barely afford to do
anything one of his great school
teachers
bought him a pair of glasses to allow
him to do the reading for school being a
chemist may have been his secondary life
goal but he really wanted to be was a
professional baseball player and he used
to tell me that his sight got in the way
of that although I have no way to gauge
whether or not his baseball was ever
going to be at a caliber to allow him to
to do that he began in fact his career
instead was that of an accountant and he
very much loved numbers and I think that
that love of numbers and the love of
things related to to mathematics very
much was embedded in me as well my
mother was an elementary school teacher
and she began by teaching English but
then actually moved into the teaching of
math and science and I remember when I
was in high school that she went back to
school taking a master's degree in
astronomy so she would be a better high
school science teacher and so I think
that the combined influences of my
parents very much set me into a state
where I was receptive to and excited
about learning about science but I think
even more than that both of my parents
loved knowledge they loved learning
things they respected it and probably
more importantly than all of that they
also love me and encouraged me really to
do i might say anything i wanted to do
but there were occasions where i think
that wouldn't quite fit anything
respectable that I wanted to do they
very much encouraged me in doing I have
one sibling a younger sister and
interestingly she also became a
biologist if she's on the faculty at the
University of Miami in Florida
our roots to biology were completely
disparate and our biological interests
are our professional lives are very
different she is a tropical ecologist
has spent much of her adult life on her
hands and knees in the jungles of
Central and South America following ants
and studying plants I have spent my
comparable time two blocks away in a
building located on the MIT campus in
the earlier days looking through a
microscope and in the more recent days
sitting talking on the telephone or
looking at a computer we grow up grew up
both of us in the city of Chicago and
then for high school I moved to a
chicago suburb I don't know if there are
any Chicago natives here yes no yes okay
so we moved to skokie and I went to high
school in skokie and through my young
education I participated in a variety of
science fairs in particular when I was
14 years old I had a science fair
project in the area of genetics which is
my field today so somehow that got set
or at least got returned to but it was
not a straight line I came here to MIT
as an undergraduate I was interested in
science the reason I came to MIT but as
an undergraduate I received two degrees
one was in mathematics and the other was
in economics I had not taken a biology
course until I was a senior in college
and really was thinking very much that I
would do something you know in the
a more public sector and I was thinking
about going to law school um just before
my senior year I had a roommate who said
to me that biology had progressed beyond
the biology I'd been exposed to in high
school it was no longer if I can say it
dried plants and formaldehyde treated
animals but rather was very vibrant and
there were all sorts of interesting
exciting discoveries that had recently
been made and he said that I should at
least look into the field so as a senior
in college I registered for my first
course in biology the professor in that
course man named side Leventhal who was
a great biology and a great human being
definitely got me interested in the
field and six weeks into the course
again as a senior in college I went to
him and I told him I found the biology
he was teaching interesting and I was
thinking about applying to graduate
school in biology based on my now
sophisticated six weeks of knowledge
happening okay and basically I asked him
is it too late he turned to me and what
he said was my undergraduate degree was
in physics my PhD was in physics I am
teaching your biology course you would
be starting early so with that and also
the fact that he agreed to write a
letter of recommendation knowing
absolutely nothing about me I applied to
graduate school in biology and as you
heard from the introductory comments
went upriver for a period of Education
and I've never turned back I've been a
biologist ever since then
and I guess my comment in the context of
these remarks for the younger people
here but also maybe for some of the
older people here too is don't be
constrained by what you quote have been
look forward to what you want to be do
what interests you and things should
work out if you do something that
doesn't interest you it's not going to
be any fun anyway okay so upriver I did
my PhD studies with two mentors James
Watson and Wally Gilbert Jim is known
for his work with francis crick in which
they discovered the double helical
nature of DNA and Wally is known for his
work on determining the DNA sequences of
molecules and both of them are Nobel
laureates jim was at the time wally was
rewarded with a Nobel Prize some years
later not because of what I did from
that institution which I gather we leave
unnamed in these quarters he's feeling
tie free I went I guess people say
across the pond i went from Cambridge to
Cambridge here to sites to Cambridge
there in England and in Cambridge
England I worked at the Medical Research
Council there it's called laboratory of
molecular biology and I worked with two
colleagues particularly closely Sydney
Brenner who was one of the founders of
the modern field of molecular biology
and john sulston and it was with the two
of them that I later shared the honor in
2002 in Stockholm
now the discoveries the primary
discoveries that were recognized with
the Nobel Prize in Stockholm wherefore
as you've heard studies of a phenomenon
called programmed cell death also known
as a pitocin for the biologists or
medical folks in the audience you
probably know that word can be and has
been pronounced at least seven different
ways we won't worry about that and I
began my studies of programmed cell
death in Cambridge England with John
Sydney and then came back here to MIT in
1978 as a faculty member and really
focused the much of the work in the
early days on that problem here I've
been on the faculty here now for its I
guess 32 years which seems pretty
remarkable and again I've looked around
but never really looked back so let me
turn now to some comments about the
science and specifically programmed cell
death what what does that mean and in
essence what programmed cell death is
referring to is cell death that is
naturally occurring part of the so
called genetic or developmental program
and what's really quite remarkable about
the phenomenon is that cells that are
generated for example as an animal
develops and in cells that form our
bodies are the bodies of any animal some
of them are generated essentially only
to die okay that seems counterintuitive
why would organisms do this and how do
organisms do this and how special is
this kind of phenomenon well in fact all
of you know some examples of programmed
cell death for example
picture a tadpole a tadpole changing
into a frog that process of
metamorphosis involves the loss of the
tale of the tadpole that tale is made of
cells cells are the basic units of life
and those cells die and those deaths are
programmed cell death if one looks at
the development of a human fetus okay
and you look in utero you would see
between the digits of such a fetus
fingers and toes that there's actually
webbed areas and those webbed areas are
cellular they're made of cells and
they're essentially sculpted out by a
process of programmed cell death okay so
there is a large number of examples of
programmed cell death in development
think about birds think about bird feet
they come in two varieties webbed and
not webbed as you can probably guess now
the difference is in the regulation of
programmed cell death and those species
that have to swim that program cell
death does not occur in that webbing
stays behind facilitating the swimming
behavior of the of the bird whereas in
those species that simply walk on
there's no webbing because programmed
cell death has occurred programmed cell
death can be a very major event if one
looks at the development for example of
the human brain and parts of the
developing human brain as many as eighty
five percent of the nerve cells that are
being generated die by programmed cell
death as we sit here today in our blood
there are cells in the immune system and
these cells are being generated
continuously and they're used for a
variety of purposes and as
many as ninety five percent of certain
types of blood cells that were making
today die by programmed cell death so
programmed cell death is widespread in
biology nonetheless this phenomenon was
basically ignored by biologists and one
might ask the question why should this
have been and we could try to analyze
that in a variety of ways but I think
one simple answer and at least part of
the answer is biologists have long
struggled hard to study cells to analyze
biology and to do so they have to keep
cells alive for example in a petri dish
and if cells died the researchers
figured they were doing something wrong
similarly in many cases if they knew
that cells died in a body of an animal
human or otherwise they figured
something went wrong with those cells
those are the cells that couldn't do
anything or that had been mistreated or
exposed to some bad thing in the
environment and so they died because
something was wrong and what we know
today and to some extent from the work
that was recognized in Stockholm is that
that's not the way to think about many
of the cell deaths that occur in biology
rather cell death can be a normal part
of the development and biology of an
animal and that really was one of our
main findings and the way we found that
was by identifying genes ok genes
control lots of who we are and what we
are and what we did was to find genes
the control program cell death if there
are genes that control the process the
process obviously is controlled by genes
in our bodies therefore it is
naturally occurring and in fact what we
found was the genes that control program
cell death act within the cells that are
going to die so that the program cell
death that occur are fundamentally
suicides these cells are killing
themselves cellular suicide is a normal
aspect of biology okay now having said
that I hope there's one message that's
come clear so far cells can kill
themselves as a normal part of biology
now think about disease any aspect of
normal human biology that goes wrong can
lead to disease and program cell death
is no exception to that as researchers
have recognized the widespread
phenomenon of programmed cell death more
and more human diseases have been
associated with abnormalities in the
regulation of programmed cell death and
these disorders can be thought about in
essentially two flavors there are
diseases in which there is too much cell
death cells that should live instead die
and there are diseases in which there
are two there is too little cell death
on cells that should die instead live
for example you've all heard about
neurodegenerative diseases diseases like
Alzheimer's disease and Parkinson's
disease and Huntington's disease and Lou
Gehrig's disease a mile trophic lateral
sclerosis ALS and two dozen other
neurodegenerative diseases in these
disorders what happens is certain kinds
of nerve cells die and in different
disorders it's different nerve cells
that's why the clinical features are
distinctive but these nerve cells are
dying and in at least some of these
diseases it's been shown that what
happens is essentially this normal
program of programmed cell death is
unleashed at the wrong time or in the
wrong cell type now that's not clear for
all of these disorders for example
Alzheimer's still a big question mark
but for others like certain d
generations of the I certain retinal
degenerations it's perfectly clear this
is what's going on there are other
disorders in which there is essentially
ectopic misplaced programmed cell death
on heart attacks heart cells die the
process is programmed cell death
congestive heart failure a different
disorder probably also true many liver
diseases many kidney disorders and I
could go on and on our disorders in
which cells are dying and what has
happened is for one reason or another
this endogenous program of programmed
cell death of suicidal cellular
destruction is unleashed causing cells
to die the other side of the coin
disorders in which cells should die but
don't certain autoimmune disorders are
of this sort okay what happens in
autoimmunity is that cells in our immune
system cells in our blood that are there
to recognize foreign bodies instead
recognize our own bodies and attack it
now those cells are generated as a
normal part of the process of the immune
system biology but normally they die so
they aren't there to survive to attack
us but in autoimmune disease they don't
die there's a deficit in program cell
death and they survive and cause disease
cancer
people generally think about cancer as
cells dividing and dividing and dividing
without bound and that's cancerous
growth and that's true but it turns out
it's only half of the story when one
looks at the number of cells in a tissue
in our bodies that number is defined by
two opposing processes cell addition
cells divide and divide making more and
cell depletion programmed cell death too
much cell division can lead to cancer so
can too little cell death it's like
think about a bathtub okay you have a
bathtub and the bathtub is half full and
the faucet is on water is coming in and
the drain is open at exactly the same
level of opening that's needed so that
water flows out at the same rate water
is flowing in from the faucet so water
is coming in waters going out the level
of the water in the bathtub stays even
turn up the faucet the tub is going to
overflow leave the faucet as it was but
slightly plug the drain and the tub is
going going to overflow cancer it turns
out is a combination of too much coming
in too much cell division and too little
going out to little cell death some
cancers like follicular lymphoma are
fundamentally diseases of too little
cell death and today it looks like
probably all cancers involve too little
cell death in addition if one looks at
the classic treatment for many cancers
radiation therapy chemotherapy these are
treatments that cause cancer cells to
die what are they doing they're active
eating programmed cell death they're
activating this endogenous process that
can cause cells to die okay so
programmed cell death is very important
in the context of cancer and more
generally very important in the context
of a large number of different diseases
okay so having said that maybe I'll turn
and make a few comments about the
research that we did okay what we did
was to analyze the biology of programmed
cell death and we didn't do this by
studying humans or a human disease and
we didn't even study a mammal like a
monkey or a mouse we studied a
microscopic worm around worm one
millimeter a twenty-fifth of an inch in
length and to work with this animal you
have to look through a microscope I
should have brought some worms and
passed them around today if I pass them
around on a petri plate and you held
them up to the light what you would see
is little things about the size each of
a piece of lint but if you look
carefully you would see it was a moving
piece of lead we studied these animals
because they are very simple for example
the animal contains 959 cells we can
contrast that with an insect depending
upon the species which has between a
hundred thousand and some millions of
cells or with us or a mouse where we
have basically something on the order of
close to a million million cells 959 ok
and we know every one of those cells and
we've known those cells by name and
parents for many years now very easy to
study an organism that's that simple
plus we did genetic studies
okay to do genetics what you want is
large numbers of animals and a rapid
life cycle we can grow 10,000 of these
worms on a petri plate this size and the
life cycle from egg to egg is three days
we can go through two generations in a
week okay much easier than studying a
mammal so by studying this animal we
were able to work out aspects of the
biology of program cell death and by we
now in referring to the three of us
Sydney Brenner john sulston and myself
but myself means not me but me and a
team of students and postdoctoral
researchers here at MIT Sydney had the
brilliant insight that this organism
would be excellent for studies of
biology he introduced the animal to
modern biology and worked out methods
for its analysis john sulston figured
out how to study and then determine the
complete cell lineage of the animal and
what this means is if you think about
any animal we start as an egg a
fertilized egg which divides to make two
cells which divides to make two more and
so on and so forth um c elegans again
has 959 cells and john traced the
complete developmental history of every
one of these cells so we knew where each
came from how each was related to each
other and furthermore if anything went
wrong with the development we had
single-cell resolution to say precisely
what had happened ok and then my lab
analyzed the genetics of programmed cell
death I back up for a moment and John
discovered in the course of his study of
the cell lineage that in addition to the
959 cells that were found in the animal
there were 131 others that were
generated but not in the adult and the
reason they were not in the adult as
they died they died by programmed cell
death as a normal part of development
what we did was ask how we looked for
genes that are involved in the process
of program cell death genes that
regulate which cells live and which
cells die and we did that by seeking
mutants genetic variants that were
abnormal in programmed cell death we
isolated and characterized many such
mutants and in this way we were able to
identify genes that functioned in cell
death in different ways for example we
identified killer jeans these jeans are
necessary for cells to die by programmed
cell death if they are disrupted by a
mutation that prevents their activity
all hundred and thirty-one cells that
should die instead live conversely we
identified a protector gene a gene that
protects cells against program cell
death if this gene is inactivated then
cells that should live instead died and
we analyzed these genes in terms of how
they function we put them into a pathway
so that we knew that there was a primary
killer and one of the other killers
activated that killer and the preventer
the protector prevented the activator
from activating the killer and another
killer prevented the protector from
preventing the killer from activating
the killer and so on and so forth so we
got a pathway a pathway of genes the
controlled program cell death and we
studied these genes in a variety of ways
including molecularly
and it turned out from the molecular
studies that they all have counterparts
they have human counterparts they have
counterparts in in fact all animals that
have been studied and the first human
counterpart that we identified was a
human counterpart for the protector gene
protects against cell death and the
human counterpart turned out to be a
human cancer gene and when all was said
and done it causes cancer because it
protects cells that should die from
living and then those cells go on and
undergo cancerous growth the other genes
also have human counterparts and it
turned out that the pathway that we
identified by studying this tiny worm
was spot-on with the pathway the
controls program cell death in us and
that can go wrong in diseases that are
diseases of programmed cell death in
addition the identification of these
genes in programmed cell death and I
should back up and say that it was not
known that most of them affect some of
these human genes hadn't been identified
yet they came about the identification
knowing about what we had found in worms
and I can remember the day that we
published the paper describing the
identity the molecular identity of one
of the killer genes and that day I got
phone calls from five pharmaceutical
companies interested in the story and
one from an old friend of mine who was
working at a pharmaceutical company who
said i have a group of a hundred people
at my company working on a human
counterpart of the gene you've just
described what are we studying because
they thought they were studying some
quite distinct medical problem ok so the
genes that we ended up identifying the
human counterparts of those genes are
now being used in the biotechnology and
pharmaceutical industry
raised as novel drug targets to
intervene with the process of programmed
cell death for example if you could
block the activity of a killer gene you
might be able to treat a disease in
which there is too much programmed cell
death a disease like retinal
degeneration or liver disorders and so
on and so forth conversely if you can
block a gene that is a protector you
might intervene with a disease in which
there is too little cell death because
you would be activating cell death and
so in this context I actually have
another hat besides the head I were
across the street I've been very
involved in the biotechnology and to
some extent pharmaceutical industries in
an advisory capacity I founded a company
based upon these findings with
programmed cell death the company was
purchased by a major pharmaceutical
company and two of the drugs that we
developed are in active pursuit one for
treating liver disease and the second
for treating certain human cancers okay
so that takes from the study of a worm
the biology all the way through to new
findings relevant to basic biology the
biology of a worm to human biology to
human disease to to drug discovery and
drug development now so far we haven't
cured anybody but we haven't killed
anybody yet either so we're list on on
the right route okay so those are those
are some of the i would say bare-bones
aspects of of the science at least part
of the science that was recognized in
Stockholm and let me just finish these
introductory comments with a few what I
would say our messages from my
experiences related to to the things
I've told you about first of all science
can very much be
a team endeavor myself I was very lucky
to have outstanding teachers and mentors
so for the young folks i would say
choose your teachers wisely you want
good teachers because they really
motivate you and they help you in
addition I've been very lucky to have
outstanding researchers working with me
outstanding post doctoral scientists and
graduate students and undergraduates and
it was really these trainees who
performed most of the experiments that
ended up being recognized in Stockholm a
second comment the research that I've
described that we did was absolutely
basic scientific research when I began
neither the generality nor the potential
application of our studies was at all
clear in fact this limited C elegans was
completely obscure at this point I was
advised not to work on it because it
would be a scientific dead-end genetic
studies are often highly abstract I
didn't target any disease and I didn't
have any idea if the research we did
would be quote relevant to any organism
other than a worm that lives in the soil
nonetheless our studies established
mechanisms that appear to be universal
among animals and also have provided the
basis for a new understanding of human
biology human disease and new approaches
to human therapeutics and so I think
there's a very important message here
basic research discovery oriented
research can be very fundamentally
important in a variety of ways first of
all it's interesting it's intellectually
satisfying and I think that's what
drives many basic research
researchers but secondly it's from
search such basic research that
unexpected discoveries come and it's
these unexpected discoveries that are
the big leaves if you're always looking
under the lamppost and always trying to
make this next step focused on something
very specific you may make that step but
it won't be as much as a surprise as you
will by doing something that is much
more exploratory basic research is
really the driver of scientific
knowledge and having said that I want to
turn a little bit to policy I mentioned
that I have a second hat that i
sometimes wear in the commercial world I
have a third hat that i sometimes wear
inside the beltway I go to Washington
and I speak with policymakers there I've
met with members of Congress I've
delivered a what's called a
Congressional Caucus about biological
research and what I try to tell people
there is about the importance of basic
research and also the importance of
federal government funding for basic
research if all of the research that is
funded first research funding is
important but secondly there must be a
portfolio of research interests if all
of the research is funded is targeted to
very specific areas then these
out-of-the-box kinds of discoveries will
never come and I would argue progress
would be much slower I don't think today
we would have the understanding of the
aspects of biology that are fundamental
to many many diseases if each disease
had been studied into and onto itself
without the kinds of basic explorations
that I was very fortunate to be able to
do initially only with funding from the
federal
government from the National Institutes
of Health the federal government must
support this work and thirdly I come
back to something I commented on earlier
for particularly the young folks don't
be afraid don't be afraid of trying
something new and also don't be afraid
if you really believe in something to go
against advice you were given I was told
I was headed for a scientific dead end
by working on this obscure organism and
I think my scientific life to date has
been anything other than that so let me
stop these introductory comments at this
point and turn it over to questions
comments and whatever well thank you
very much indeed so we're going to use
the rest of our time for Question and
Answer I take a couple from here then
I'm going to hope to fit in at least one
from our friends in Cairo so please use
the microphones if you're going to ask
and I see a first question or just in
the front here how does the field of the
genetic control of apoptosis relate to
epigenetics do are there similar
mechanisms of methylation of the genes
to activate and inactivate as we see in
other areas of epigenetics okay so let
me first define for the the general
group what epigenetics is and also let
me say that there is religion around
this word just like around the
pronunciation of a pitocin and also let
me say that I have recently founded a
company about tech company in the area
of epigenetics so I'm very happy to to
talk about the field and in fact my
laboratories research on epigenetics I
was related to the other component of
the Nobel Prize about which I've said
nothing to date but the Nobel Prize that
I received had two components and our
epigenetic work stemmed from the other
half okay first of all at the genetics
and let me back up to Jim
products okay so genetics is are
basically the classical study of
heredity genetics is the study of genes
we all have genes and our genes are what
make us human our genes are to a great
extent what make us different from each
other our genes defiant our eye color
our genes define many aspects of who we
are but not all now it turns out that
very recent research has indicated that
genetics is only part of the answer to
heredity okay there are her editable
changes okay so let me go back to genes
for a moment changes in genes are
changes in DNA genes are bits of DNA
okay and changes in genes are
alterations in DNA small alterations big
rearrangements amplifications of parts
of DNA all of these lead to very
variations in humans and also to certain
diseases there's another aspect of
heredity that does not involve changes
in DNA sequence and these this aspect of
heritable traits has come to be known as
epigenetics beyond genetics and
basically to think about epigenetics we
have to think about the DNA and a
slightly more expansive way so our DNA
is found in chromosomes and our
chromosomes contain two basic components
DNA and protein very different kinds of
molecules okay and the protein the major
protein ah but not by any means the only
protein associated with DNA
our proteins called histones ok so the
histones basically the the what happens
is you get the DNA of double helix that
wraps around a set of histones and then
that whole business is folded up and
then those folded up things are folded
up again and all of that is packed into
our chromosomes now the histones and the
DNA can be modified in ways that are
distinct from mutations for example a
certain chemical moiety a methyl group
can be added to the DNA there are a
variety of chemical modifications that
can be made to the histones and these
modifications can alter the DNA histone
chromosome structure locally in ways
that affect which genes are expressed in
which genes are not expressed so that
epigenetics basically involves a series
of alterations either to DNA or to
histones or to the arrangement of
histones and particularly groups of
histones known as nucleosomes along the
DNA and those differences can be
inherited so it's a whole second
universe of heritability and sometimes
that heritability can be from generation
to generation parent to child and in
some cases it's heritability from cell
to cell so if you think for example
about again the single-celled fertilized
egg dividing and dividing to make all
the cells in our bodies one of the
things that's happening there is that
there are these modifications of DNA and
histones that get inherited so the
patterns that you'll see in a set of
nerve cells will be different from what
you see in a set of blood cells will be
different from what you see in a set of
muscle cells okay
and all of those are examples of
epigenetic inheritance okay so that's
epigenetic and now I have to apologize i
forgot the question just use the mic if
you could because no one else can hope
is there methylation involved in the
switching on and off of the genes
responsible for apoptosis as there is
for other epigenetic phenomenon okay so
epigenetic phenomena as I've just
alluded to our major aspects of ways in
which genes are controlled but not the
only aspects and there are examples in
mammals where there are indications that
there is epigenetic regulation of some
of the genes that I've alluded to but I
would say it's still very early days we
have found hints in the worm of such
regulation so that we know that some of
the genes that are involved in
epigenetic regulation can also regulate
indirectly aspects of program cell death
but we don't know how we haven't figured
that out at all so the answer is I'm
sure going to be yes but at this point
it's still a bit in the future thank you
okay I'm going to try and take a
question now if I may from our friends
in Cairo if they're listening and can
hear us do you have a question for
professor Horvitz please
people are asking about his basic
research for developing countries like
Egypt and his input on how sectors in
and in particular conclusion to act the
best one is when cancer we just as a
quick aside yes so some questions about
the professor Horvitz your role in
arguing for the role of basic research
in the developing country context first
I think okay that's an excellent
question and one that I think is very
important so the argument is sometimes
made that the wealthy country should be
the ones who spend the money on basic
research and the countries that have
more limited resources should focus on
problems particularly problems in
agriculture and health that are specific
to those countries and my feeling about
that is is that it's not quite so simple
and the reason is that the quality of
science that is done is driven by the
quality of scientists who are doing it
and that quality is very much dependent
upon the sophistication and experience
of the researchers so I will argue and I
have argued that in developing countries
it is very important to maintain a part
of the expertise and a part of the
research portfolio in areas that are
basic so that those people who are doing
things that are more applied one have
the resource and to have access to
people with a finger on the pulse of the
most recent technologies and the most
recent discoveries exactly where to draw
that line is very complicated and very
difficult and it reminds me of an issue
that I dealt with about 20 years ago
with the world health organization where
the World Health Organization was
focused very much on problems in poorer
countries problems and health of health
and poorer countries and the question
was even more extreme than that the
question was for every dollar available
is it better to spend it on available
medicines and tree
somebody or on research that might make
better medicines and treat a greater
number of people and that's a very
difficult problem and the discussion of
that issue involved not only biologists
and clinical clinicians knowledgeable
about medicine but folks from the world
of economics and folks from the world of
policy and the answer as most people
would guess was not all or none again
there has to be a portfolio but exactly
how to define that portfolio is a very
complicated socio political economic and
scientific issue if I could just say
thank you the other very big issue that
was raised by our friends in Cairo was
to do with the current state of cancer
research and we're where we are in terms
of finding better treatments for disease
I realize it's a huge issue but you may
want to comment on it ok well I can talk
we can talk about cancer and we can go
beyond it to other disorders the first
thing to say about cancer is cancer is
not a disease cancer is many many
different disorders and even cancers
that have labels breast cancer liver
cancer colorectal cancer are not single
entities onto themselves and so as we
think about trying to treat cancers we
have to remember that there are a
multiplicity of diseases and each may
need some aspects of different approach
having said that the science is getting
better there are some cancers
particularly cancers of young people
where there have been very powerful
cures that have developed over recent
years there are other cancers that are
fundamentally still intractable what the
field of cancer biology is doing today
is hoping to better delineate the
different cancers understand the
biological basis of the different
cancers and develop drugs that can be
useful in one or more of these k
is at the same time learning the phrases
to fractionate patients to understand
for a single patient what disease that
patient really has and therefore which
drugs are most likely to be useful and
which drugs are likely in fact in some
cases to be harmful so the knowledge is
progressing the problem is not easy and
again there's a multiplicity of problems
and I i would say that there is progress
being made that is much slower than
everybody wishes it would be a but with
the proper resource there will be more
progress I cannot begin to give an
answer to when cancer will be cured the
only thing I can tell you is that when a
recent director of the National Cancer
Institute made an announcement that
cancer would be cured within 10 years of
the field of cancer biology jumped up
and said you can't say that yeah thank
you that's a question down here nope
your own ah what is it like to win a
Nobel Prize where you were when you how
the news or reaction or does it change
your walk or life or whatnot right so so
the first answer I would say is does it
change your life and the answer is yes
and I was amazed the day it happened to
think that now everybody I knew knew
somebody who had a Nobel Prize
um where was I and also I lad did I know
ahead of time so i was aware ahead of
time that it was possible i had been
aware that people had nominated me and
in fact MIT is not unaggressive in
informing people that they are at least
thinking about it so for a number of
years prior to the 2002 announcement i
got phone calls from the MIT press
office asking me where i would be on the
day of the prize announcement which by
the way is always the the first monday
in october for medicine okay 2002 I
didn't get such a call so i figured MIT
knew something i was no longer on the
list it wasn't going to happen so so be
it where i was actually well it depends
what what source of information you use
if you use the new york times as a
source of information i was with my
family vacationing in the French Alps if
you know the life of a faculty member at
MIT is unlikely and think about October
when I teach my course in genetics you
could suspect that that couldn't have
been the whole story so where I was with
my family indeed was the French Alps we
had gone to France for the weekend
because our young daughter had had a
French au pair and this all pair was
getting married so we went for the
wedding the wedding was on saturday we
went to the wedding on saturday we spent
time with the family on sunday and we
took off monday to spend extra because
it was after the wedding so we would
have some time with our are basically
our daughter is the way we feel about
her and her new husband so we were there
monday one day beyond the weekend
vacationing in the French Alps okay now
on that morning on monday morning my
daughter wanted to go out to the lake
she had heard about from her or pair
where she could catch crayfish now if
you know the elves in October it's not
so warm so we went out there it was
freezing cold my daughter who was nine
at the time went out didn't matter the
cold waited in collected a few
crustaceans everybody else was frozen
and we went back to the home of the
author's parents and when we walked in
her father who speaks no English and I
learned later no Swedish either said to
me essentially you had a phone call and
what I heard was from Boston and I'm
thinking if I had a phone call from
Boston having been gone for a weekend
this is not good the lab burned down
something horrible happened so I tried
to find out more and as he repeated it I
heard him say Stockholm okay well that
had some interest I I knew what day it
was that had not escaped my attention
and that caught definitely caught my my
interest but i also have a friend who
told me a friend who won the Nobel Prize
but told me that some years before that
he had had a phone call from someone
with a Swedish accent that awoke woke
him at five thirty in the morning in New
York and told him all sorts of things
and it turned out to be a friend with a
rather perverse sense of humor so I
started thinking about friends with
perverse senses of humor and I could
come up with quite a list so I wasn't
very confident and I asked her father
again you know well tell me more and he
basically said I don't speak English so
I didn't understand but I wrote down a
number
but he didn't write down a number in
numbers he wrote down a number
essentially in letters of the sounds
that he thought he heard and numbers so
i called that number and i got sweden
but it was a number not in service so
then what well what we figured we would
do is we would turn on the television
and turn on the radio and watch and
listen and see if anything happened and
we did that for about half an hour my
wife at one point got very excited about
the weather report but French isn't very
good better than mine and at one point
the all pair heard a report on the radio
that said that indeed I had received the
Nobel Prize said who Michael recipients
were and what the announcement was and
that was how I heard Wow well look it's
it's a shame I wish we could go on but
unfortunately our time is up and I think
we ended on a really appropriate note
you can hear about a Nobel Prize
apparently in many different ways
including from the au pair so I know
that you like me of all found
fascinating this glimpse of the life of
a Nobel prize-winning biologist I'd like
to tell you that there's a chance to
have a glimpse of another Jack szostak
tomorrow it's same place same time but
in the meantime please join me in
thanking professor Robert Kovac
thank you very much
you